another book that i read around the same
time
that had a big impact on me uh
and and there was actually a little bit
of overlap with john pierre as well and
i read it around the same time
uh is jeff hawkins on intelligence
which is a classic and he has this
vision
of the mind as a multi-scale hierarchy
of temporal prediction modules and these
ideas really resonated with me
like the the notion of a modular
hierarchy
um of you know potentially um
of compression functions or prediction
functions
i thought it was really interesting and
it reshaped uh
the way it started thinking about how to
build minds
the hierarchical nature the which aspect
also he's a neuroscientist so he was
thinking yes actual
he's basically talking about how our
mind works yeah the notion that
cognition is prediction
was an idea that was kind of new to me
at the time and that i really loved at
the time
and yeah and the notion that yet there
are multiple scales of processing
in the brain the hierarchy
yes this is before deep learning these
ideas of hierarchies
in here i've been around for a long time
even before on intelligence i mean
they've been around since the 1980s
and yeah that was before deep learning
but of course i think these ideas really
found
their practical implementation in deep
learning
what about the memory side of things i
think he's talking about
knowledge representation do you think
about memory a lot
one way you can think of neural networks
as a kind of memory
you're memorizing things but it doesn't
seem to be
the kind of memory that's in our brains
or it doesn't have the same rich
complexity long-term nature that's in
our brains
yes the brain is more for sparse access
memory so that you can actually retrieve
um very precisely like bits of your
experience
the retrieval aspect you can like
introspect
you can ask yourself questions again yes
you can program your own memory
and language is actually the tool you
use to do that
i think language is a kind of uh
operating system for the mind
and use language uh well one of the uses
of language
is as a query that you run
over your own memory use words as keys
to retrieve specific experiences of
basic concepts specific starts
like language is the way you store
thoughts not just in writing in the in
the physical world but also in your own
mind
and it's also how you reach with them
like imagine if you didn't have language
then you would have to you would not
have really have a
self internally triggered a way of
retrieving
past thoughts you would have to rely on
external experiences
for instance you you see a specific site
you smell this basic smell and it brings
up memories
but you would not really have a a way to
deliberately deliberately access these
memories
without language well the interesting
thing you mentioned is you can also
program
the memory you can change it probably
with language yeah using language
yes well let me ask you a chomsky
question
which is like first of all do you think
language is like
fundamental like
uh there's turtles what's at the bottom
of the turtles
they don't go it can't be turtles all
the way down is language at the bottom
of cognition of everything
is like language the fundamental
aspect of like what it means to be
a thinking thing no i don't think so
i think language you disagree with norm
chomsky yes
think language is a layer on top of
cognition so
it is fundamental to cognition in the
sense that
to to use a computing metaphor i see
language as
the operating system of the brain
of the human mind yeah and the operating
system you know is a layer on top of the
computer
the computer exists before the operating
system but the operating system is how
you make it truly useful
and the operating system is most likely
windows not
not linux because it's uh language is
messy
yeah it's messy and it's it's pretty
difficult to
inspect it introspective how do you
think about language
like we use actually sort of human
interpretable language
but is there something like deeper
that's closer like like logical type of
statements
um like yeah what is the nature of
language do you think like is there
something deeper than like the syntactic
rules we construct is there something
that
doesn't require utterances or
writing or so on are you asking about
the possibility that there could exist
uh languages for thinking that are not
made of words
yeah yeah i think so i think so
uh the mind is layers right and language
is almost like the
the outermost the uppermost layer
um but before we think in words i think
we think
in in terms of uh emotion in space
and we think in terms of uh physical
actions
and i think uh babies in particular
probably express his thoughts in terms
of
the actions that they've seen of that or
that they can perform
and in terms of the in in terms of
motions of objects in their environment
before they start
thinking in terms of words it's amazing
to
think about that as the building
blocks of language so like the kind of
actions and
ways the babies see the world as like
more fundamental than the
beautiful shakespearean language you
construct on top of it
and we we probably don't have any idea
what that looks like right
like what because it's important for
them trying to
engineer it into ai systems
you